in a previous video we talk about the
notion of equivalence with equations
and equivalence is just this notion that
there's
different ways of writing what are
equivalent statements in algebra and i
could give some simple examples
i could say 2x equals 10 or i could say
x equals 5. these are equivalent
equations why are they because an x
satisfies one of them if and only if it
satisfies the other and you can verify
that in both cases x equals 5 is the
only x that satisfies both
another set of equivalent equations you
could have 2x is equal to 8 and x equals
4. these two are equivalent equations
and x satisfies one if and only if it
satisfies the other
in this video we're going to extend our
knowledge of equivalence to thinking
about equivalent systems and really in
your past when you were solving systems
of equations you were doing operations
assuming equivalence but you might not
have just been thinking about it that
way
so let's give ourselves a system
so let's say
this system tells us that there's some
xy pair where 2 times that x plus that y
is equal to
8
and that x plus that y
is equal to 5.
now
we can have an equivalent system if we
replace either of these equations with
an equivalent version so for example
many of you when you look to try to
solve this you might say well if this
was a negative 2x here maybe i could
eventually add the left side and we'll
talk about why that is an equivalence
preserving operation but in order to get
a negative 2 out here you'd have to
multiply this entire equation times
negative 2. and so if you did that if
you multiplied both sides of this
times negative 2
times negative 2 what you're going to
get
is
negative 2x minus 2y is equal to
negative 10.
this equation and this equation are
equivalent why because any xy pair that
satisfies one of them will satisfy the
other or an xy pair satisfies one if and
only if it satisfies the other
and so if i now think about the system
the system where i've rewritten this
second equation and my first equation is
the same
this is
an equivalent system to our first system
so these any xy pair if an xy pair
satisfies one of these systems it's
going to satisfy the other and vice
versa now the next interesting thing
that you might realize and if you were
just trying to solve this and this isn't
an introductory video in solving systems
so i'm assuming some familiarity with it
you've probably seen solving by
elimination where you say okay look if i
can somehow add these the the left side
to the left side and the right side to
the right side these x's will quote
cancel out and then i'll just be left
with y's and you we've done this before
you can kind of think you're trying to
solve for y but in this video i want to
think about why you end up with an
equivalent system if you were to do that
and one way to think about it is what
i'm going to do to create an equivalent
system here is i am going to
keep
my first equation 2x
plus y is equal to 8
but then i'm going to take my second
equation and add the same thing to both
sides we know if you add or subtract the
same thing to both sides of the equation
you get an equivalent equation so i'm
going to do that over here but it's
going to be a little bit interesting so
if you had negative 2x minus 2y is equal
to negative 10 and what i want to do is
i want to add 8 to both sides so i could
do it like this
i could add 8 to both sides
but remember our system is saying that
both of these statements are true that
2x plus y is equal to 8 and negative 2x
minus 2i is equal to negative 10.
so instead of adding explicitly 8 to
both sides i could add something that's
equivalent to 8 to both sides and i know
something that is equivalent to 8 based
on this first equation i could add 8
and i could do 8 on the left-hand side
or i could just add 2x plus y
so 2x plus y
now i really want you you might want to
pause your video say okay
how can i do this
why is cell saying that i'm adding the
same thing to both sides because
remember when we're taking a system
we're assuming that both of these need
to be true an x y pair satisfies one
equation if and only if it
only if if and only if it satisfies the
other so here we know that x 2 x y needs
to be equal to 8. so if i'm adding 2x y
to the left and i'm adding 8 to the
right i'm really just adding 8 to both
sides which is equivalence preserving
and when you do that you get
these negative 2x and 2x cancels out you
get negative y is equal to
negative two
and so i can rewrite that second
equation as
negative y
is equal to
negative two
and i know what you're thinking you're
like wait when i'm used to solving
systems of equations i'm used to just
adding these two together and then i
just have this one equation and really
that's not super mathematically rigorous
because the other equation is still
there it's still a constraint oftentimes
you solve for one and then you quote
substitute back in but really the both
equations are there the whole time
you're just rewriting them in equivalent
ways so once again this system this
system and this system are all
equivalent any xy pair that satisfies
one will satisfy all of them and vice
versa and once again we can continue to
rewrite this in equivalent ways
that second equation i could multiply
both sides by negative one that's
equivalence preserving and if i did that
then i get
i haven't changed my top equation 2x
plus y is equal to 8 and on the second
one if i multiply both sides by negative
1
i get y is equal to 2. once again these
are all equivalent systems i know i'm i
sound very repetitive in this but now i
can do another thing to make this to to
keep the equivalence but get a clearer
idea of what that xy pair is
if we know that y is equal to 2
and we know that that's true in both
equations remember it is an and here
we're assuming there's x y some xy pair
that satisfies both 2x plus y needs to
be equal to 8 and y is equal to 2. well
that means up here where we see a y we
can write an equivalent system where
instead of writing a y there we can
write a 2 because we know that y is
equal to 2. and so we can rewrite that
top equation by substituting a 2 for y
so we could write rewrite that as 2 x
plus 2 is equal to 8
and
y is equal to 2. so this is an and right
over there it's implicitly there and of
course
we can keep going from there i'll scroll
down a little bit i could write another
equivalent system to this by doing
equivalence preserving operations on
that top equation what if i subtracted 2
from both sides of that top equation
it's still going to be an equivalent
equation
and so i could rewrite it as
if i subtract 2 from both sides i'm
going to get 2x is equal to 6 and then
that second equation hasn't changed y is
equal to 2. so there's some xy pair that
if it satisfies one it satisfies the
other and vice versa this system is
equivalent to every system that i've
written so far in this chain of
operations so to speak
and then of course this top equation an
equivalence preserving operation is to
divide both sides by a non the same
non-zero value and in this case i could
divide both sides by 2
and then i would get if i divide the top
by 2 i would get x equals 3
and
y
is equal to 2. and once again this is a
different way of thinking about it all
i'm doing is rewriting the same system
in an equivalent way that just gets us a
little bit clearer as to what that xy
pair
actually is
in the past you might have just
you know just assumed that you can add
both sides of an equation or do this
type of elimination or do some
substitution to just quote figure out
the x and y's but really you're
rewriting the system you're rewriting
the constraints of the system in
equivalent ways to make it more explicit
what that x y pair is that satisfies
both equations in the system